the Internet has a little-known and
mysterious twin known as the dark web
it's a place where online services
offering illicit drugs and hitmen are
just one click away the murder of a
mother in the Midwest led to 48 hours
Peter Van Zandt into the shadowy world
of the dark web his six-month
investigation uncovered murder plots
that were paid for but not yet carried
out 48 hours alerted authorities around
the world hoping to save lives here's a
look at what 48 hours discovered my name
is yaara he calls himself Europe and in
this video diary claims to run a
murder-for-hire empire on the dark web
it's a kind of an Internet hiding behind
the one we know Yura has struck terror
in the hearts of people all over the
world including 43 year old Amy Alwine
in Cottage Grove Minnesota they seemed
like an all-american church-going caring
loving couple so prosecutor Jamie
Chrysler says in May 2016 Amy and her
husband Steven seemed shocked when the
FBI and police informed them
she was marked for murder someone had
placed a kill order for $12,000 on a
dark web hitman site called basa mafia
using an anonymous screen name dog day
god Dog Day God says I need this dead
there was an urgency right you every dog
day God is chomping at the bit for this
to happen captain Randy McAlister says
the all whines beefed up security and
bought a gun
November 13th 2016
sergeant Gwen Martin was on the night
shift when police got a 911 first
responders to the scene were suspicious
Amy had a single gunshot wound inside
her right ear it soon became clear
someone had killed her was it the hired
hitman from the dark web 4,000 miles
away in London a white hat hacker
named Chris Montero had been monitoring
yuras basa mafia site what a dog day God
want done the target kill on a given
date he says it listed dozens of kill
orders from all over the world he says
he tried to alert authorities but they
brushed him off so he started passing
tips directly to 48 hours we found
ourselves in the middle of an apparent
live marketplace for murder and there
was only one thing we could do we
contacted authorities they just received
a tip for a murder-for-hire in Iran a
citizen of Taiwan if it wasn't for 48
hours there would have been a funeral so
far four arrests from our tips do you
understand the terror that you have
caused with this murder-for-hire plot
Wow Peter Van Zandt is here Peter you
and an investigation that literally
saved lives how many murders were
prevented we're up to more than 30
targets in nine countries these are
people who were a kill order had been
made and money had exchanged hands and
you talk about the dark web aside from
the name itself what makes it so
dangerous what makes it dangerous is
that it's everything you do on it is
virtually untraceable it was created by
the United States military so commanders
could have secret communication criminal
organizations have gotten into the dark
web it requires a special browser to do
so and so so much goes on and no one can
trace what's happening so you can
actually go on and say I'd like to have
this person murdered negotiate all of
that and nobody knows this is happening
so conflicted about us even telling this
story Peter because on one hand it gives
people ideas on the other hand shouldn't
we be doing something to shut it down
it's remarkable how many people already
know unlike you I had night narrative
the dark web but what has to happen now
the FBI CIA and other national
intelligence agencies in various
countries have to unite because they
have the technology to shut these guys
down
well Dog Day God should be warned that
you and 48 hours are watching
yes exactly and you can see the two-hour
season premiere of 48 hours click for a
killer tomorrow night at 9:00 8:00
central right here on CBS